ist adhs heilbar und müssen unbedingt
medikamente her um gegen adhs anzugehen
adhs betroffene sind unruhig können sich
nicht lange konzentrieren und im kopf
herrscht pures chaos doch diese
aufmerksamkeitsdefizit
hyperaktivitätsstörung ist alles andere
als eine mode erkrankung wahrscheinlich
litten auch schon viele bekannte
persönlichkeiten wie beispielsweise
albert einstein oder aber wolfgang
amadeus mozart darunter die wissenschaft
ist der erkrankung auf der spur und
gewinn ziemlich spannende erkenntnisse
klicks umsatz im future gibt es dreimal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und activity glocke
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen das video heute ist
übrigens in zusammenarbeit mit dem kanal
behindert zu wort entstanden unbedingt
abonnieren der link ist er unter mir
dort gibt es noch mehr infos zu adhs aus
der sicht der betroffenen selbst für die
betroffenen ist es das reinste chaos das
im kopf herrscht kein wunder denn
adhs-patienten patienten fehlt ein gut
funktionierender reiz filter im gehören
stefan leidet unter der
aufmerksamkeitsdefizit
hyperaktivitätsstörung und beschreibt
das so für mich fühlt es sich so an
stellt euch vor das gerne seine gäste
mit einzelnen musiker designer musiker
sind sozusagen die neuen programme damit
eine symphonie des denkens und handelns
entsteht brauchen wir einen dirigenten
oder auch gedanken manager genannt der
dirigent sorgt dafür dass die einzelnen
musiker im park korrekt und zur
richtigen zeit spielen war der es ist es
so dass der wirkend die aufnahme der
information zu wenig regelt und so
entsteht keine symphonie ist sondern es
gibt chaos so fühlt es sich bei man und
das führt nicht nur bei den betroffenen
selbst sondern auch in ihrem privaten
umfeld zu belastungen nach angaben des
robert koch instituts wurde adhs in
deutschland bei knapp fünf prozent der
kinder und jugendlichen von einer ärztin
oder einem arzt diagnostiziert bei
weiteren fünf prozent gibt es hinweise
auf adhs somit zählt die erkrankung zu
den häufigsten kinder psychiatrischen
störungen die betroffenen müssen mit
symptomen wie unaufmerksamkeit
hyperaktivität und impulsivität klar
kommen die kinder und jugendlichen
können sich nicht konzentrieren hören
nicht zu zappeln herum verlieren
gegenstände und machen dinge nicht zu
ende
die symptome machen ihnen viele bereiche
des leh
ist einfach schwer und lassen den alltag
zum kampf werden und das oft auch bis
ins erwachsenenalter hinein lange gingen
fachleute davon aus dass sich diese
störung herauswächst doch mittlerweile
gibt es einige us studien die das
gegenteil nahelegen
demnach zeigen bis zu 50 prozent der
kinder die unter einer adhs leiden auch
in ihrem erwachsenenalter deutliche
symptome tragischerweise ist diese
störung in der gesellschaft dennoch noch
immer ein tabuthema
das erzählt auch einheit mit reizen
wurde um ihr adhs festgestellt damals
war die krankheit ist populär und
konnten nichts mit anstand
der test wurde mir gemacht weil ich
ziemlich unruhig war konnte stoffen
stuhl sitzen bleiben war ziemlich
abgelenkt und ziemlich auch draußen das
liegt an den krankheitsbild ich kann
nichts dafür
und das ist man schon selbstverständlich
andere menschen
doch mit einer diagnose tut sich die
medizin und psychologie sehr schwer denn
wo verläuft die grenze
schließlich haben die wenigsten kinder
lust ruhig da zu sitzen fachleute waren
dass kinder in manchen fällen zu
vorschnell medizinisch behandelt werden
weil sie stören oder nicht den
erwartungen der erwachsenen entsprechen
auf der anderen seite gibt es aber auch
viele erwachsene die schon in ihrer
kindheit merken dass sie irgendwie
anders sind
doch es gab nie eine diagnose betroffene
sprechen von einem großen leidensdruck
denn von der gesellschaft werden sie
schnell als faul oder dumm oder
respektlos bezeichnet fest steht
jedenfalls dass drei kernsymptome für
die diagnose adhs definiert sind
hyperaktivität impulsivität und eine
beeinträchtigte aufmerksamkeit die
entsprechende leitlinie sagt aber auch
dass es sich nur dann noch ein
krankhaftes problem handelt wenn das
impulsive und unaufmerksame verhalten in
kombination mit einer deutlichen
hyperaktivität mindestens sechs monate
lang besteht das verhalten der
betroffenen mädchen jungen entspricht
somit nicht dem entwicklungsstand von
gleichaltrigen das alles führt dann zur
beeinträchtigung in sozialen lebens
bereichen egal ob in der schule oder im
kindergarten und auch bei betroffenen im
erwachsenenalter gibt es probleme sowie
bei stefan ich gerate schnell in stress
vielleicht umgebracht bin kein morgen
mensch aber liegt das an der ads also
ich rate leicht gestresst wenn ich viele
aufgaben gestellt bekommen haben auch
sehr viele gedanken was schief gehen
könnte
aufgrund meiner idee ist habe ich auch
schon
erlebt dass ich an manche sachen nicht
geschafft habe das führt auch zu ein
bisschen niedrigen selbstwertgefühl
grund meine idee ist habe ich auch ein
paar vorteile für mich ich kann sehr gut
ins tor machen ich habe oft viele gute
neue ideen viele einfälle vielleicht
andere nicht zu haben mein spezialgebiet
ist die recherche ich kann viele
informationen aufnehmen und das hilft
mir dabei relevante themen aus den
printmedien wie das social media team zu
finden
durch die vielen den filtern mein gehirn
nämlich mehr sachen aufwands andere das
kann vorteile aber auch nachteile haben
ich kann nicht alles ausblenden
platzieren informationen bekommen
das ist oft schwierig aber manchmal kann
das ein vorteil sein heißt also auch
wenn der alltag für viele adhs-patienten
patienten eine riesige herausforderung
ist kommt ihnen die erkrankung in
mancherlei hinsicht auch zugute
viele von ihnen haben ein großes talent
kreativ zu denken weil ihr reiz filter
schwächer ist nimmt ihr gehirn super
viele informationen auf diese werden
unstrukturierter und somit auch offener
verarbeitet so kommt es häufig zu
überaus innovativen und kreativen
gedanken und ideen dazu heißt es auf der
webseite des selbsthilfevereins adhs
deutschland ev wenn diese menschen für
sich die richtige nische gefunden haben
sind sie häufig genial und unschlagbar
in ihrem sprühen eifer und ihren
unermüdlichen aktionismus und so
vermutet man in der fachwelt dass viele
bekannte persönlichkeiten aus der
vergangenheit auch an form der adhs
erkrankt waren beispielsweise thomas
edison und einstein wolfgang amadeus
mozart oder auch der politiker winston
churchill adhs wird somit häufig als ein
phänomen bezeichnet das sich zwischen
genie und wahnsinn bewegt doch was sind
die ursachen von adhs forschungsteams
weltweit können auf diese frage noch
keine eindeutige antwort geben denn die
erkrankung ist äußerst komplex fachleute
gehen aber davon aus dass es nicht die
eine ursache für diese störung gibt
sondern verschiedene faktoren eine rolle
spielen klar ist jedenfalls dass den
patientinnen und patienten ein gut
funktionierender reiz filter im gehirn
fehlt eine stoffwechselstörung also die
dazu führt dass manche botenstoffe im
gehirn nicht ihre volle wirkung
entfalten können wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler sprechen von
neurotransmittern wie serotonin
noradrenalin und dopamin die in zu
geringer
menger ausgeschüttet werden oder aber zu
schnell wieder abgebaut werden
dabei sind sie enorm wichtig um signale
zwischen den nervenzellen weiterzuleiten
denn so funktioniert die steuerung
darüber wie unser gehirn einströmende
reize filtert und verarbeitet im
klartext kann man das ganze so
zusammenfassen die hirnbotenstoffe
laufen bei adhs betroffenen also auf
sparflamme und der hirnstoffwechsel ist
viel reguliert dadurch funktioniert der
reiz filter im gehirn und mangelhaft
wodurch die typischen symptome
hervorrufen werden die ads erkranken
können sich nur schlecht konzentrieren
lassen sich leicht ablenken und sind
impulsiv reinhardt hat einen weg
gefunden damit umzugehen
manchmal wenn ich dieses stück komme und
schreibe whatsapp gruppen dann kriege
ich die leute für mich ein ganz falsches
bild und steckt mit einer schublade rein
oder mache ich sorge mich dass ich dann
sind verstörend drauf bin manchmal habe
ich auch kreative phasen und kreativen
schübe wo ich mich positiv entwickeln
kann ich mache viele collagen bach
bilder macht modellbau und einfach meine
leidenschaft damit meine gedanken damit
in form zu gießen
ich zeige den bildern so was ich mir
vorstelle wo meine gedanken und meine
visionen drin sind und einfach so eine
gefühls laune hält eben bild
auszudrücken
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
gehen davon aus dass adhs vor allem
genetisch bedingt es doch auch
psychosoziale faktoren scheinen eine
rolle zu spielen
studien offenbaren dass eltern mit einem
niedrigen sozialstatus doppelt so häufig
von einer adhs diagnose ihres kindes
berichten als eltern mit einem hohen
wird der status eine depression der
mutter und auch emotionaler stress in
der schwangerschaft könnten das risiko
einer späteren adhs beim kind erhöhen
auch tabak und alkoholkonsum während der
schwangerschaft sind nach ansicht der
fachleute deutliche risikofaktoren
laut einem bericht des robert koch
institutes ist die adhs diagnose bei
jungen verbreiteter als bei mädchen
anders bei einer sonderform der
aufmerksamkeitsstörung ads genannt
hierbei fehlen die typischen merkmale
der hyperaktivität die erkrankten sind
vergesslich verträumt
sogar geistesabwesend von ads sind mehr
mädchen als jungs betroffen dazu stefan
harder ist er um kurz der dritte typ und
positiv zu verhaltensweisen also ein
bisschen verträumt werden bei der es um
positive verhaltensweisen vorlegen die
leute sehen oft ungefragt in gesprächen
dazwischen fahren gerne zu schnell auto
unterschätzen die gefahr oder
schwierigkeiten hin was die schlangen zu
wahren unterschied liegt also darin dass
die leute von ags eher verträumt sind
und die leute mit adhs impulsiver sind
und starke innere unruhe aufweisen
forschungsteams weltweit suchen nach den
besten therapie möglichkeiten meistens
werden mehrere ansätze miteinander
kombiniert so bekommen die ads
erkrankten nicht nur psychotherapie
verschrieben sondern auch medikamente
besonders wichtig ist es aber auch dass
die familien unterstützung bekommen um
so wieder ein gutes familiengefühl
herzustellen denn ansonsten kann es zu
weiteren negativen folgen kommen
für mich ist das schwierig neue leute
kennenzulernen weil viele haben nicht
das verständnis dafür mit hds umzugehen
spielt das müssen runter dass ich ein
spiel beherrschte aber nach kommt es
doch irgendwie raus und da viele leute
kein verständnis dafür hat sich noch im
heim war wurde ich um 20 uhr ins bett
geschickt und das sogar noch mit 16 17
jahren
beide treffen mit dir haben wollten und
weil ich so aufbrausend war und das
schulzentrum springenden verhalten auch
früh gemobbt damals war die kirche so
populär und nicht jeder konnte damit
anfangen hat eben und dabei stellt der
außenseiter ich habe mich dabei ziemlich
mies gefühlten durch sind auch
depressionen entstanden klare regeln und
strukturen im alltag können helfen
genauso wie die reduktion von reizen
aber auch das training des sogenannten
neuro feedbacks kann helfen
hier lernen patientinnen und patienten
ihren aktivitäten gezielt zu steuern
auch so kann das chaos im kopf abnehmen
konkret geht es darum diejenigen
hirnströme zu trainieren
die für eine bewusste konzentration
notwendig sind eine der großen fragen
lautet medikamente ja oder nein
häufig werden substanzen wie amphetamine
oder bitdefender verschrieben das kennt
man auch unter dem begriff ritalin diese
wirkstoffe sollen den hirnstoffwechsel
anregen und botenstoffe freisetzen das
gehirn uns damit also deutlich aktiver
und das über stunden hinweg die
konzentration der botenstoffe steigt bei
den adhs erkrankten damit auf ein
normales level
doch die medikamente bringen auch
risiken und langzeit folgen mit sich und
sind noch nicht ausreichend erforscht so
kommt es bei kindern beispielsweise
vermehrt zu kopfschmerzen oder
schlaflosigkeit dass die wirkung von
ritalin umstritten ist hatte auch eine
große metaanalyse vor einigen jahren
2015 offenbart demnach verbessert mit
fanny tat wohl die lebensqualität der
kranken kinder und hilft auch gegen die
typischen symptome doch die datenlage
dazu ist äußerst dürftig und das
autorenteam der bekannten kopfhörer ins
kollaboration schreibt unsere
erwartungen an diese therapie sind
wahrscheinlich größer als sie sein soll
eine pilotstudie auf den usa konnte
zeigen dass es neben der medikamentösen
ansatz auch weitere möglichkeiten gibt
die begleiten und helfen könnten ein
kurzes sporttraining nämlich die 36
männlichen probanden sollten vor einem
aufmerksamkeits und
geschicklichkeitstests 20 minuten auf
einem trimmrad fahrrad fahren
die kontrollgruppe dagegen sollte
einfach nur 20 minuten ruhig dasitzen
das ergebnis überraschte zwar schnitten
die probanden nach dem fahrrad training
in den test nicht besser ab doch fühlten
sich die jungen männer deutlich besser
laut der studie fühlten sich die
teilnehmer weniger konfus weniger
erschöpft und depressiv und war
motivierter die aufgaben anzugehen dazu
schreibt das autorenteam bewegung ist
dafür bekannt stress zu verringern und
die stimmung zu heben sport hat daher
auch das potenzial menschen zu helfen
die unter adhs symptome leiden andere
arten des sports könnten wahrscheinlich
auch die kognitiven leistungen der
betroffenen verbessern wir glauben dass
eine andere trainings art oder dauer
sogar noch größere effekte bei
adhs-patienten zeigen könnte als die
eher langweilige einheit auf dem
trimmrad im sterilen labor und es gibt
einen weiteren vorteil anders als
medikamente sind hierbei ja auch keine
nebenwirkung zu erwarten also es ist
sehr spannend was sich da in diesem
bereich im bereich sport noch in zukunft
für forschungsergebnisse zeigen werden
doch wie groß sind die heilungschancen
oder ist die devise einmal ads adhs die
wissenschaft ist derzeit auf dem stand
dass ads zwar therapierbar aber nicht
heilbar ist wichtig ist es vor allem die
psychosoziale situation der betroffenen
zu verbessern und zu stabilisieren dazu
der mediziner peil damals
die medikamentöse behandlung hat keine
direkten effekt auf den langzeitverlauf
aber die psycho sozialen und emotionalen
begleitumstände besser sich das feld den
patienten immer leichter sich an ihr
umfeld anzupassen häufig ins dann eines
tages eine medikamentöse behandlung
nicht mehr nötig enorm wichtig ist es
also mit adhs umzugehen und sein leben
entsprechend zu gestalten
die diagnose ist dazu der erste wichtige
schritt so wie bei stefan dessen leben
sich dadurch enorm verbessert hat wenn
mir wurde 2007 die diagnose ads gestellt
es hat gut getan zu erfahren woher die
schwierigkeiten in der schule
schwierigkeiten nicht im berufsleben
hatte und zu erfahren wo man
schwierigkeiten nichts organisieren
herkommen jetzt nachdem ich ja wusste
was ich hatte konnten sie endlich auch
mit der behandlung der symptome beginnen
das hat mir sehr gut getan nach all den
jahren wo ich bestimmte schwierigkeiten
haben eine erklärung dafür gefunden habe
falls sie in zukunft menschen trifft die
unkonzentriert oder zerstreut werken
denn translator wandelt sich in
erkrankung werde es liegen könnte
hier geht es weiter mit chaos im kopf
menschen mit adhs erklären adhs
unbedingt anklicken anschauen und
behindert vor ort also hier unbedingt
drauf klicken und behinderte und
abonnieren
das social media team mit menschen mit
behinderung kann sich in mönchengladbach
bei der stiftung hephata betreue und es
ist wirklich etwas ganz besonderes hier
machen menschen mit behinderung als
social media team zusammen youtube das
gab es so noch nie deswegen liegt mir
sehr viel daran
und sie freuen sich wirklich riesig über
jedes abo also bis dann bleibt dran